welcome to this video playing Papa Papa
Papa type I'm not really great with
those kind of French names she got a
name in there Quentin new soul and I am
yeah so many I am surround okay okay
let's see what do we get an english or
its blacks next choice now okay so we
all get and 93 was actually a bit more
flexible hmm that was stupid I wanted to
go for this position but first doing
that c3 is just the more flexible choice
okay so mm okay let's let's try one of
those setups in which it might be useful
to not having plate plate deform okay v5
that was very early isn't this just good
for wide if i take on d5 let's see you
night be five this is normally the
problem with this very early five in
this position okay so here's some just
accepting them the lost some of the
bishop pair okay i guess i also should
take yeah i should take it question is
what to do now whether black asses and
black has a decent center it cannot be a
really in bad shape yeah so um maybe I
just don't know the idea just deform or
B should be five putting pressure on I
don't know if you should be five could
be an interesting way to play yeah why
not actually
it seems that like um oh this I didn't
really consider at all hmm interesting I
thought it's a bit bit just does not
have any any big merits to attack the
Queen maybe I'm wrong hmm what is he
doing maybe just push it a five to come
by but he 5 is hanging yeah okay I'll go
here keeping d3 and c2 under under
control and what is he doing now I mean
low key 8 is not possible now which I
thought would be the the normal way to
protect the pawn when the night was
still on c6 you can go efore but this is
certainly a move that I i don't mind
giving me the nice d foursquare for my
night interesting so
I'll just drop background right yeah I
guess so I don't really see something
else and what now again I'm double
attacking a five with Bishop enter and
night so I wats a wonder if he can maybe
do something I did for it ok now is
giving me this this great square one
deform yeah that's an interesting way to
play try to use the d3 square the
question is if I really should do should
play this very slow move Bishop to
everyone try to not exchange it could be
an idea could be an idea okay I don't
want the straight that allows this night
to d3 and they don't really see a big
drawback at the moment o Queen deform is
a move that I must keep in mind Queen D
for Bishop de 492 and then I need to
give up my queen as well but it's not a
big deal looks perfectly okay for me
yeah an interesting position I just I
only expect more by not Bishop to age
five years you know is playing that yeah
I was actually planning g4 and I'm down
a long time so I need to play a tent at
some point okay but would be too right
why should I planes like Bishop to e3
okay this looks fine what could eat what
could he do here exactly i was just I
was just going to mention that neither
to a 25-23 could be an idea okay um try
to get rid of this night so that it's
not going to be a nuisance on d3 to just
taking it here okay yeah this may be
coming with knight c6 simply
n96 I try to be ready to recapture with
the Queen yeah this is a really a bit of
a loose position that I have it would be
quite okay with Queens off for example
but it's not so apparent how I should
should manage that where is my king
actually going does not have a really
good natural square yep 92 I need to
speed up him one minutes 22 I'm trying
to do something on the long diagonal
night f5 and possibly know this is G
fibers now I know I protected yeah i'm
not i'm not sure at all here the knight
on d4 is a very strong piece at the
moment but he can always try to exchange
it with 96 so it's not at all clear to
me
how I should play here Quincy 3 is going
to play Queen design problem now my king
position is cause for concern it's got
no attack at the moment but I'm not sure
how to get the rook to the C file
tonight which is probably what would
would help my cause maybe just 2g two
women it looks shaky but I cannot invade
at the moment I'm the default light is
controlling see one
now maybe just push a v6 here could be
could be a simple in good move I really
I cannot play for when really i try to
but i'm giving away a three not a good
idea trying for our queen c7 but you can
take a three now i think i will get in
quincy seven essence is quite okay yeah
he blundered away the spawn check check
this is a good good position already am
in complete control I believe trying to
get to the a pawn
no no no luck resigned no and now we
resigned yeah i mean i made a mouse slip
obviously while trying to recapture i
played the g5 and where this was totally
weird and but okay I just just need to
recapture and and it's very easy mostly
yeah when will the tense game I mean
this is a interesting an interesting
position really maybe I'll Quincy five
is a strong move here very strong def
yeah this is a very very strong move and
loses immediately for me 92 and the
bishop is hanging so I need to do
something else a Quincy one problem this
also means that probably Bishop b5 is
not such a great at the end I was also
thinking about deform i'm a bit behind
in development yeah this this might
prove to be a problem yeah okay but
let's look a bit more at this position
which I initially thought would be quite
good he and why am I not going bf3
actually that's about it dad I mean okay
this is a playable move it's not totally
terrible but I can't do f3 actually
which I didn't really consider yeah
that's just a pretty good position for
white actually if you look at this I can
use the g file like google g1 at some
point I just got Bishop g6 maybe I need
him maybe first this smooth yeah it's um
it's still unclear I never really get a
good king good king position f3 looks a
bit looks a bit better we are here Mike
making position is simply insecure but
he didn't really get to the king um here
i'm still in trouble i believe they are
playing for winnie as wide as a bit
insane that okay only here i will
starting to feel comfortable the king is
safe now is too much exchanged for the
attacker being any dangerous and down
yeah this snow is good for wide if i get
queens off then this whole structure is
really a bit weak than term yeah the
very shaky game alright thanks for
watching